Open!
Squid.
Octopus?
Either one.
What are these things?
What does it look like?
Suction cups.
Oh my goodness!
Is this the lung?
Didn't that have so many arms?
You mean like this?
Oh my goodness, eww!
What is this?
It's an octopus tentacle.
Oh, but what is this from?
An octopus?
What is that?
That's an octopus tentacle.
Can I see?
I may have octopus finger!
All I'm missing is the face.
This one's chewy.
Too chewy.
In fact, you chew it forever and then you're just going to lose your appetite...
...trying to eat it.
And open!
What are these?
They look like marbles.
Orbeez?
Orbeez and sushi?
What does it feel like?
What the heck?
Oh, fish eggs.
It's popping in your mouth once you bite it.
Is that a good thing or a bad thing?
It's a good thing because it's like egg.
Guess what, those are fish eggs.
Fish eggs.
Why did I eat fish eggs?
Because they're so delicious.
I know, but did you cook them?
We didn't.
It's urchin.
Is this alive?
It is not alive.
They smell different.
The sea urchin only uses a spike for defense.
Sea otters use them to protect their babies.
Right now, it would be injecting poison.
Two facts about sea urchins.
Well, that was the last one.
How about a big thing of wasabi to finish us off.
Delicious.